hey everyone
ever since ethereum was introduced in
the blockchain space with its presence
in 2015 new decentralized applications
have been developed by vitalik buterin
however smart contracts are a big part
of ethereum's success
these new contracts are referred to be
smart contracts since they're
significantly more functional than their
paper-based predecessors
there is no mention of ai a smart
contract is a set of digital agreements
that include protocols for the parties
to fulfill
those promises
so considering its popularity and
uniqueness i from simply learn have
brought you a new video on how to create
an ethereum smart contract
so without any further delay let's get
started with video
but before starting please do subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update from
simplyr
so let's start with the coding journey
to our first ethereum smart contract
but before diving into the development
and deployment of ethereum smart
contracts it's critical to first grasp
the ethereum platform and how it
functions
so the first thing that we learn is what
is smart contract in the first place
so smart contracts are essentially
programs that run when criteria are
fulfilled
and are stored on a blockchain they are
usually used to automate the execution
of an agreement
so that all parties can be certain of
the results right away
so without the need of any
intermediaries or time waste they can
also automate a workflow starting the
following step when certain
circumstances are satisfied
so now that we know what this smart
contract let's move ahead and see how it
works
so
step one
smart contracts are made up of basic if
when
then phrases encoded in code on a
blockchain
step 2 when preset conditions are
satisfied and validated the activities
are carried out by a network of
computers
these measures could include sending
notifications releasing funds to the
proper persons or issuing a ticket
step 3 when the transaction is completed
the blockchain is updated
that means the transaction can't be
modified
and the results are only visible to
those who have been granted access
there can be as many stipulations as
needed
convince the participants that the task
will be executed correctly participants
must agree on how transactions
and associated data are represented on
the blockchain
agree on the if when then rules
actually govern those transactions
investigate all conceivable exceptions
and design framework for resolving
disputes in order to set the terms
the smart contract can then be coded by
a developer the firms that use
blockchain or business are increasingly
providing templates web interfaces and
other online tools to make smart
contract construction even more easier
and here also we will be using one such
tool to create our very first ethereum
smart contract
so now that we know all the required
knowledge about smart contract let's
start with how to create
our very first ethereum smart contract
so let's get started now let's start
with the first smart contract so the
first thing that we need to do is to
navigate to this website which is
remix.ethereum.org
so this is going to lead us to a remix
ide
as you can see which is an integrated
development environment for solidity
programming
and it runs from the browser itself so
it does not need to be installed or
and you can access it in any operating
system
so it's a lot more convenient and you
can also use it to interact with the
ganache or test net over rpc port
so basically rpc or remote procedure
call interface is provided by the
blockchains for the execution of the
functions that you will store or that
you'll
insert as a criteria in your solidarity
smart contracts
so here we will be using ganache to
deploy our smart contracts
so let me give you a quick introduction
to ganache basically it's a personal
blockchain
that enables the building of ethereum
and coda distributed applications
quickly
and it may be used throughout the
development cycle allowing you to
develop deploy and test your
decentralized applications
in a secure and a very predictable
environment
but before uh deploying our smart
contract on ganache we will deploy a
smart contract on the default blockchain
provided by the remix itself
so
let's get started with the code
so the first thing that we need to do is
to create a file with dot sol extension
so
let's
you can see here i have already created
my workspace with the name of demo smart
contract workspace
now i just need to create a file
you can click on this icon
and
you can give it a name according to your
convenience or whatever program you're
gonna
store in your
smart contract
so
basically dot sol is the extension to a
smart contract since we are using
solidity programming
to create our smart contract
so
i'll just
give it a name
so here i have given it a
name called democontract.sol
and that is it now you can see here
you have directed to a
section where you have to actually write
your code
so basically in this video we will be
creating a smart contract
for the implementation of cryptocurrency
in its most basic form
so this smart contract will allow you to
create or mint new coins and send them
to other blockchain addresses
so
let's start with our code so the first
thing that we will write is
fragma directive
so let's
write
pragma
solidity
0.5.1
so this is basically a
range of our minimum margin for our
solidity server
then we will declare the
contract
so let's just write contract
so basically the core contract code
starts with a keyword
the contract followed by the name of the
contract according to your convenience
so here i am giving it a name
mint
your
coins
and
then the braces which employ the entire
contract state and its functions
so now that we have declared our
contract scope let's start with the
variables and functions that we need to
declare in our smart contract
as per our need
so here i am declaring our variables
so the first variable is for addresses
first one is
mentor
and
second is
balance
so these are known as state variables or
this mapping can be thought of as hash
tables that are virtually uh initialized
so that every potential key exists
right away and is mapped to a value with
a
byte representation
of all zeros
so this map will store every address
with its balance
so now that we are done with the
declaration of our variables let's
create a constructor
that that will be the address for
creating
new coins
so
instructor
we will
make it
public
minister
dot
ms
g dot
sender
so
this line ensures that only the creator
can mint new coins
next we will set a condition for
creating new point
and
storing them in the
hash table
so
now to store our created new coins into
a hash table we'll declare a function
mint
so let's start with the code
function
address of
the receiver
and the
amount
to be
received
we'll also declare this public
and we just need to uh
mention our
conditions here
so this is our first condition second
we'll mention
the limit
for the maximum number of coins to be
created
or
for the maximum number of
you know the amount to be
received or sent
this system
so
the next function is going
to be sent which simply examines the
transactions feasibility so let's
declare that function as well
so
again
let's
input our parameters
address of the receiver
and
the amount
will make this function public as well
mention our
criterias
so
the first one is
so this is for you to check if
there's sufficient balance or
insufficient balance
in the account
so if the transaction is possible the
function will generate a send sent event
so we also need to mention
an
event here
to know
all the details like
who has the address of the sender and
the receiver as well as the
amount
so here we have created the event
now let's get back to the criteria in
our send function
so
as i was saying uh if the transaction is
possible the function will generate a
sent event
which is a declaration for the
transactions to be
broadcasted so let's just
get done with our
criteria here
a month
so the clients
using ethereum can listen to these
events on the blockchain for free the
listener receives the arguments from
from
or to
an amount as soon as the event is
emitted right
here in the
sent function
sorry i forgot to mention too yeah
so
as soon as the event is emitted
uh the transactions is
dragged and then
the next function is executed which is
to get the balance of the address
also when the transaction is completed
the transaction is then added to the
blockchain itself with all the details
of who has
sent those
coins and who has received it according
along with their addresses
so let's
create one more function to know the
balance
so that will be
let's
give it
the argument
external view returns
for the return value
that will be integer
return
balances
on the argument we just
mentioned
so this function is to
get the balance off
of our account
so this was our code now we need to
compile this code
see if there is any error or not so
to compile this you need to click on
this icon
and just click
on compile
so here you can see that there is no
error and it's successfully compiled
so once it's compiled you need to deploy
this code
so click on this uh icon
here you can see this is the by default
environment uh
environments provided by remix itself so
we will just
select the default one javascript
virtual machine
so like we discussed before before or
deploying our smart contract
over ganache blockchain we will be
deploying it over the blockchain that is
by default provided by remix itself
so
here we have selected the environment
these are the accounts
with the dummy coins already stored
obviously you can't
use them for your actual purposes but
these are the dummy accounts provided by
the remix
for
analyzing your smart contracts and
keeping the track of the transactions
so you can simply select any of
these accounts according to your choice
and
as you can see there is
currently no contract
deployed here so simply we will just
click on deploy
so here you can see it's successfully
uh deployed we'll just click on this
drop down menu
and
after scrolling it down we can see all
the options with the functions like
mint send balance balances and the mento
so when you click on mentor
it will generate an address
current users address so just copy it
so once you have copied you can just
click on balance
so here you can see
you're getting error because right now
you have not
transacted any amount of coins yet so
we just
paste the address here
and
then provide the second argument which
is the
amount
that you want to mint
just click on mint and here you can see
it's success you have successfully
minted
uh
500 coins so now when you
check the balances
uh we are still getting errors sorry i
forgot to provide the address so we will
just provide the address and click on
balance
here you can see
the function is already called
and here you can see the amount you just
minted
same as for here
click on it the amount you just minted
now to send
you can just click the dress
comma
250 so for demonstration i have provided
the address of obviously
the sender right now because i don't
know the address of the receiver but
what you can do is you can provide any
other address and just
put the amount and
click on send and when you will check
the balance there will be a
change in it right now there is no
change because both the dresses are
already same
so this was all this was
the code and this is how you can
just compile and deploy your code on any
blockchain so now that we have checked
it over the default blockchain provided
by remix
let's have a look at the ganache one
so to use ganache you need to first
download it
so by clicking here you can just
download it for windows
so i have already installed this so
we'll just
jump to that step directly
so once you're done with the
installation of ganache you can you'll
get
a
page like this and then you have to
create a workspace so
you don't need to create a workspace
here you can simply click on quick start
and it will
give you a list of accounts and all the
details of the blockchain that you can
simply connect with your ide and
to which you can simply deploy your
smart contract into so let's just wait
for it to download all the information
so now here you can see all the default
accounts provided by the balance
information
by the ganache itself
what we need to focus on is our pc
server
so basically this is uh
this is the address
provided to every
ganache
account or blockchain by defaults itself
so we just need to copy this
and click on ethereum ide
and go to the environment and select
web3
provider so
when you will click on it you will get
this popup and
at the end point
you have to paste the address you copied
from your ganache
portal and
just click on
ok
so now you can see again uh
there is no contract deployed to it
because now you are simply connected to
the custom network which is your ganache
network
now
these are the accounts provided by you
provided to you by ganache itself the
list of accounts that you saw on the
portal now
the same process you need to repeat here
just click on any account of your choice
select it
and
click on
deploy
so here you can see it's successfully
deployed
and again we're going to repeat the same
process
so you can see the address is completely
different from the previous one
just copy this
paste it here
let's have a different amount this time
or let's put it
750.
so and just click on mint
you can see it's successfully minted and
when you
will paste the address here and
click on balance you can see it's
showing 750 same you can
do for balances
it's 7.50
and the same you can do with the sent
also as i'm using the same address there
will be no change
in the balance
but obviously it's not popping any error
and showing it successfully done
so
you can use it with somebody else's
address too
so this was all about your first own
created smart contracts
i hope you enjoyed this video and
learned something new from it please do
like this video and if you have any
queries related to this topic or this
video you can simply comment down in our
comment section our experts will
reach you out as soon as possible thank
you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here